yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm John and
in this video i'm revealing trolls world
tours hilarious deleted ending with the
Bergin's Bridget and gristle plus 14
more amazing deleted scenes and songs
you never got to see as the credits roll
on the final version of trials world
tour we get a fun dance partying song
that finishes with a cool cameo by
everyone's favorite bergen's Bridget and
gristle but there's an arguably even
funnier post credit scene that we almost
got papi these are the three cloud
babies we see riding around with cloud
guy and his girlfriend in the credits of
the final movie and of course the
cutscene is also a fun riff on how guy
Dimond gives birth to tiny diamond papi
come quick it's an emergency
guy diamond what's wrong I'm having a
baby the deleted credit scene continues
in the vein of a cheesy family based TV
sitcom complete with canned laughter as
we see cloud guy trying to take care of
his kids
[Music]
join the messenger
[Music]
what the heck's this sack of garbage no
thank you
and that hilarious ending with bridges
and gristle watching the show on TV
might well have been another Bergen
cameo appearing right at the very end of
the credits in addition to the
mid-credits scene we got in the final
movie Oh Chrissy I guess we're late to
the party Oh balls it ready but who's
gonna eat my cheese balls babe the first
trailer patrols world tour features a
scene cut from the final movie of papi
singing the sound of silence together
with the same weird and wonderful forest
creatures that accompanied her when she
sang the song in the first trolls film
[Music]
according to the trolls world tool wiki
this deleted scene of Bob crashing poppy
song was how the movie was originally
going to begin and instead of Bob's pet
bat
Debbie delivering an invitation to queen
poppy this was going to be how poppy
discovered that there were other troll
tribes another deleted trailer scene
shows King troll acts handing over the
techno string to Queen Bob I'm going to
unite the six strings and destroy all
music so I'm gonna need your strange and
if you look carefully at this cutscene
you'll see that it would have revealed
that the techno string was held in
techno beat drop button as the middle
blue string he normally has on his head
is now missing the scene might have been
cooked because techno beat drop button
appears at the end of the movie with all
his strings intact
even after all of the six strings have
been destroyed cloud guy had a
relatively small part in trolls world
tour just narrating the opening scene
and briefly dancing on stage with the
other trolls at Barb's concert
originally though there was a deleted
scene in which poppy branch biggie and
dinkles bump into him again one guy
cloud guy labid grumpy pants a fist bump
old times sake no that would have been a
call back to wing cloud guy pranked
branch in the first movie
no let you slide with a fist bump who
Jack Attack no no no no jellyfish in the
cutscene cloud guy would have also
introduced us to his new girlfriend
guys this is Janet we're dating Janet
and cloud guy too loud guy that's a
couple names Janet does make a brief
appearance in the end credits of the
final movie where the two clouds already
seem to be acquainted and give each
other engagement rings which makes a
little more sense now we've seen this
missing moment how long have you guys
known each other 10 minutes and we're
gonna last forever whoa slow your roll
Romeo that seems a bit much this early
we'll talk about this later honey bunny
no we won't angel cake cheddar cheese
sugar booger Jane
oh you didn't yeah well that's it
relationship over I mean this was a
bicycle meant for two Janet boy given
that the pair split up in this deleted
clip it seems that we were meant to
interpret the final movies credit scene
as them getting back together by the way
during their breakup we can see how
similar they are when Janet uses the
kind of dramatic word fade the cloud guy
liked to use in the first movie Janet
and cloud guy were just doomed to fail
fail fail fail certain death death death
death rocky fans would have probably
enjoyed the next part of this deleted
scene too
but you guys were such a cute couple
yeah and we ruined it guess we were just
too different hope that doesn't happen
with you two
oh no no no see you know we're just
friends no no no no just it's just just
friends just ran out my boyfriend all
right
the cloud romances seem to move pretty
quickly in the trolls world because
janet has a rebound already set up with
a thunderstorm cloud well time to move
on
winds are changing Hadi odda besides my
rebounds here rebound with Sheila be
popped the trolls hurtle towards the
ground below fortunately though poppy
finds some gum and they blow bubbles
that act as parachutes helping them land
safely they swallowed my gum
Oh next up is a cool duet with branch
and hickory but just before we dive into
that I want to thank the sponsor of this
video Full Sail University if you've
ever wondered about learning the skills
to break into the film or animation
business but don't know where to begin
check out Full Sail University whose
graduate students have landed jobs and
award-winning movies and TV shows
including How to Train Your Dragon Toy
Story 4 and Avengers n game full sales
film bachelor's degree program immerses
you in the world of filmmaking from
every angle you'll gain practical
experience while learning what it's like
to work in a film from start to finish
giving you a feel for the role each crew
member plays in a production and the
computer animation degree program guides
students through the same production
pipeline used in professional Studios
from storyboarding sketching and visual
development to more
in character animation and final
compositing these degrees are offered in
an accelerated format to get you into
the field faster if you want to find out
more about these film programs and how
to get started visit Full Sail dot edu
slash flicks in the city to learn more
the fun song that was sadly cut from the
movie was a big musical number where
branch and hickory sang an ode to poppy
who they called the queen of pop this
deleted song with storyboarded by
DreamWorks artist Jeremy Bernstein and
his son in a country style a little bit
of this original theme was kept in the
final movie when chicory sings a short
country song to branch accompanied by
singing River reeds though in the final
version the song he sings is Patsy
Cline's I fall to pieces the giant river
eel like creatures that swim under the
boat in this deleted scene also appeared
in unused trolls world tour concept art
of the trolls telling each other ghost
stories the great deleted scene with the
movie's antagonist sees barb rocking up
at an old diner in her world destruction
tour angler bus inside the diner are
groups of trolls whose musical styles
are no longer very popular so they're
sitting around feeling very sorry for
themselves singing your heart out nobody
cares not fun easy but all that changes
now you've all heard of pop music I
think they're so great because they're
popular but you guys are gonna help me
change that lil miss polka the Mariachi
sisters
the barbershop boys and Jack's the
smooth jazz er hey babe the smooth jazz
troll then almost hypnotizes barb with
his laid-back tunes that's enough
save it for queen poppy which of course
he does later in the actual movie with
poppy and branch Barb's reward for
Poppy's capture is also a little
different in this cut for whoever brings
me Queen poppy and her string will be
the opening act on my world destruction
tour whereas in the actual movie Bob
offers the winning bounty hunters a tiny
refuge for their own music I don't know
it looks pretty taming you want it or
not a sneaky yodelers also get a
different introduction in this deleted
scene if you really want the job done
right you'll need a couple of your lusts
yeah we will find this queen poppy and
we will stop at nothing the yodel is
true identity is still kept a secret
though with hickory and dickory hiding
behind a pair of beer glasses what's
also interesting about this deleted
scene is this instead of barb using a
group of bounty hunters that only
represented less popular music in the
final film DreamWorks also included kpop
and reggaeton trolls because they wanted
to make sure that there was more musical
diversity in the film and their two very
popular genres in an alternate version
of the movie poppy and Co were going to
meet hickory before they arrived at
Lonesome flats home of the country
trolls see a troll just like us I say we
steer clear
now branch we're out here to build
bridges if we steer clear how can we
make new friends yeah more like making
new enemies
but despite Poppy's enthusiasm the
encounter with Hickory has a spaghetti
western type vibe as they all I each
other up suspiciously hi there I'm Queen
poppy after all
oh you be gone only two legs
I'd say never thing hickories comments
about papi only having two legs and not
four like him for a hint to his secret
identity as he's also really just a
two-legged yodeler troll pretending to
be a four-legged country troll to keep
up his disguise Hickory continues to act
as stressful around poppy crazy
tumbleweeds come from don't take kindly
to being ambushed no no we come in peace
in fact I'd like to make a peace
offering of drumroll please tankini
remember that cotton candy is what poppy
was carrying on Sheila B there's a plan
to make friends with Bob in the final
film and I hope you didn't eat all the
cotton candy because barb is gonna love
it and Poppy's sugary offering finally
sweetens up chicory when he tries it
[Music]
well howdy that's the right tasty treat
thank you kindly names Hickory we're
gonna need you for another song early in
the movie that ended up getting cut took
place on the Sheila B balloon I was
going to show poppy revealing her plan
for saving the troll Kingdom we're gonna
find other trolls all we have to do is
come together and embrace our sameness
the original scene for this was
storyboarded by dreamworks artist john
mag room and features poppy singing to
the tune of can you feel it by the
jacksons it's a fun and zany musical
number which shows how poppy thinks a
solution to Barb's attempt to take over
the world with rock is to shower pop
music uniformity over everyone instead
the cut scene mixes a dreamlike quality
with the look of Poppy's scrapbooking
and shows her blanketing the troll
kingdom with pop music glitter sparkles
and hearts her eyes and mouths blast out
multicolored rays of light over the
other trolls turning their eyes into
hearts and them into a string of happy
pop troll puppets branch who we know is
resistant to some of Poppy's excessive
exuberance uses one of his pointy sticks
and a rock to smash one of the hearts
poppy is spreading everywhere only for
her to stick it back on him where it
expands and smothers him the deleted
song reveals that Poppy's blind to just
how oppressive her ideas really are and
shows some unflattering parallels
between her and barb in the way poppy
turns other trolls into pop music
zombies just as barb later turns them
into rock music zombies in the end the
filmmakers decided the song was slowing
down the story too much so it was curse
the small deleted scene at the beginning
of the movie saw Cooper having a
conversation with a reflection of
himself about whether he thought he was
really from one of the other troll
tribes hey you do you think I'm one of
these different kind of trolls come on
me I'm just a reflection you have to get
out there and find out
I have to get out to this wire world and
find out for myself I can always count
on you me thanks that means a lot to me
both
although the scenes amusing and reminded
me a little of Disney's original Mary
Poppins movie the wordplay is possibly a
little confusing which may be why it
ended up being cut however a snippet of
this idea was used in the final film
when Cooper's reflection talks back to
him in a mirage oh oh when poppy and her
entourage arrive at Symphony Ville they
meet pennywhistle who tells them all
about the destruction Bob and the rock
trolls wreaked on the classical Kingdom
a deleted scene which was cut for time
showed more of what happened and
revealed that pennywhistle was actually
symphony ville security guard in the
scene we see how the little tin whistle
unfortunately took a short break from
her post just before the rock trolls
arrived Oh came from a union break
a nice little detail in this missing
moment is that we would have seen that
penny whistle was a model citizen having
repeatedly won Symphony bills Employee
of the Month award the deleted scene
also showed a full-on battle between the
classical and rock trolls with the
classical trolls almost winning
[Applause]
oh dear
in the final film when the rock trolls
attack vibe city the funk trolls ready
themselves for attack Rock is right it's
all prepare for battle but the battle
never takes place as the rock trolls cut
the power to vibe City however concept
art by Timothy Lam shows that originally
DreamWorks plan to have a proper music
battle between the funk trolls and the
rock trolls as the fight between the
classical and rock trolls was also
deleted we never got to see any actual
battles between the tribes and instead
in the final movie Bob and her gang
seemed to quickly overwhelm any
resistance they encounter another cut
moment revealed in concept art shows
that when poppy and Cobra imprisoned in
Lonesome flats they were going to
discover the skeleton remains of
previous prisoners inside their Jail
this morbid joke would have fit with the
country troll somewhat sad and macabre
take a life that we heard in the song
born to die after hickory bust poppy and
the gang out of jail they end up running
off the edge of a canyon into the river
below as they flee from the country
trolls however what we didn't get to see
in the final version was this scene of
them almost drowning in the river of
yarn in the final movie we just see
poppy and branch washed up on the
riverbank instead the only element of
this original idea which did make us
into the film is dinkles vision of
ascending to heaven for a minute there I
thought you'd kick the bucket as more
concept art reveals another cutscene of
branch saving poppy pulling her out of
the river the purpose of this drawing
was also to figure out what the trolls
would look like when they're wet because
there isn't any real water in the trolls
world as even the water in the river is
designed to resemble shiny gossamer
fabric in another deleted scene on the
water we would have seen Cooper meeting
a mysterious character called bridge
fisherman as he crossed the river on his
quest to find his troll tribe this furry
looking troll is quite different from
any other trolls in the movie and if you
to discover more deleted characters from
trolls world tour such as the k-pop boy
band the giant funk troll king or the
classical cooper trolls tap here to
watch my trolls world tour deleted
characters video will follow the link in
the video description links will be here
as soon as it's ready and if you love
the amazing artwork by the DreamWorks
artists featured in this video you can
discover much more of it in the art of
trolls book and on their instagrams
there's links to those in the video
description below so do you wish any of
these deleted scenes or songs have been
included in the movie leave your
thoughts in the comments tap left to
learn all about the cool Easter eggs you
missed and trolls world tour or tap
write for something else you're sure to
like and if you enjoyed this than a like
and sure are hugely appreciated thanks
for watching and see you next time you
PK movie lovers